they call this stretch of lenore shore
the seven-mile miracle there's a
world-class surf break every hundred or
so yards we rescue up to a thousand
people a year definitely one of the most
dangerous stretches of beaches in the
world
my name is Tao Hanuman and I've been a
lifeguard for 14 years here on the North
Shore I work here at a kite beach park
it's the home of the surf break Banzai
Pipeline which is a very dangerous wave
that breaks the very shallow water it's
such a critical wave that if you fall
down the chances of getting injured of
hitting the reef is very high even when
it's really small we have very strong
powerful rip currents it's very easy to
get swept out in the rip current and not
be able to make it back to shore just
yesterday the lifeguards made about 20
rescues
knowing that the possibility of drowning
is very real you know especially a large
surf we all train my training consists
of running the beach of swimming
anything basically in my area we do mock
rescues if the surf is big I'll tell one
of my partners hey go go out and get
pounded in the surf I'll come get you
with the rescue tube so he'll go out and
you know he's taking waves on the head
and you know see how fast we can get to
them
whatever the ocean is going to do if
someone needs help and you have to go
get that person you got to be ready to
do that you're putting yourself in a
very risky situation but knowing that
your partner has your back there's it
builds a strong sense of camaraderie we
have a good morale between us all we do
this job for the love of the job
basically if you can save another
person's life it's very rewarding for
sure
you